if there's one theme that unites almost
every story we've seen for the past
three years it's the people in charge
despising the people they're in charge
of politicians despising their voters
preachers despising their congregation
generals despising their infantry
officers and enlisted men so it
shouldn't surprise you that the Bud
Light executive in charge of Bud Light
hates people who drink Bud Light and
thinks really they should all become
transsexual here she is
so I had this super clear mandate it's
like we need to evolve and Elevate this
incredibly iconic brand what does evolve
and elevate mean it means inclusivity it
means Shifting the tone we had this
hangover I mean Bud Light had been kind
of a brand of
Friday kind of out of touch humor and it
was really important that we had another
approach
yeah Freddy is bad they're just so
entitled that's the word from Alyssa
heiner Scheid who went to Harvard where
it turns out she is something of a
fratty pastor self Henry Rogers of the
Daily Caller somehow got these pictures
of that same person at school in 2006
and you can see she's blowing up condoms
and no that's not in a biology class
that's in some kind of fratty setting
so how's Bud Light doing the brain she's
partly in charge of well it's lost more
than five billion dollars in market cap
since going trans was it worth it of
course it was Candace Owens is the host
of Candace she joins us tonight to
respond hope you weren't a Bud Light
investor Candace
fortunately I was not an Amna and I will
say this nothing says I hate Friday
quite like blowing up a condom at a
Booze Fest which is exactly what she's
doing in those photos you can't make
this up but I am going to have to defend
her because listen she's lying because
she has to lie of course she enjoys a
frat culture of course she had a good
time while she was in college every
other person but now to survive in World
culture you have to become a liar you
have to pretend that you think fat is
beautiful you have to pretend to be race
obsessed you have to pretend that you
think Dylan Mulvaney is a woman and
should be included in female spaces we
are being told that you have to lie
repeatedly in order to survive in
corporate culture and she is herself a
victim of that in a perpetuator of that
so yeah it's absolutely shameful and she
should feel ashamed that she brought
this idea to Bud Light but I do believe
that she was conditioned I mean she went
to Harvard what do we think goes on what
do we believe is the sociology of people
that graduate Harvard they're basically
being told that this is the way that
they should think and there's one more
thing I want to say here Tucker because
it's deeply upsetting to me there's a
post analysis that needs to happen here
on why it is that Dylan Mulvaney for 365
days was able to openly mock women to
openly take the spaces of women to get
contracts from Ulta beauty to take you
know contracts from other women all
these sponsorships and nobody cared
until suddenly Dylan Mulvaney traversed
into a male space and it became
unacceptable why because men don't
tolerate this level of lies in the way
that women do right we respond
emotionally and not rationally we should
have been the ones to put an end to
Dylan Mulvaney but we didn't because we
feel bad and shouldn't we just feel bad
for men that want to be women and mock
us and put on lipstick and pigtails and
call themselves a girl I think not
Tucker but what culture says yes
as usual you've taken it to a much
deeper more profound level than I that I
had thought through that is so I mean in
in one sentence it's pretty amazing that
the Battle of sexist has been won by men
with the help of feminists isn't it
absolutely amazing unfortunately once
again men have to rescue women from this
terrible ideology that is taking place
right now and I commend men for doing
that
the great Candace Owens thank you so
much for that
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight